ali murad notre invité est en direct et
des professeurs de droit et activiste
politique
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors première
concrétisation des menaces françaises
quel est donc le message aujourd'hui
bonjour je pense que le message est on
peut dire facilement le ras-le-bol de la
diplomatie française la france a essayé
de dd ou de jouer un rôle dans la
solution de la crise politique la crise
économique libanaise depuis depuis
octobre 2019 et c'était toujours une
impasse déjà il faut qu'on parle de
l'impasse face à l'as à ce qu'a dit le
chef de la diplomatie française 7,7
cette attitude inacceptable et
irresponsable de la part des
responsables politiques libanais dans la
formation du gouvernement mais aussi
dans la lah dans la sortie de la crise
ça c'est quelque chose qui est qui et
qui étiez ses talents c'est une demande
de la population libanaise depuis des
semaines mais en même temps là depuis
des mois plus tôt vers maintenant il
faut voir que ça c'est un parce qu'à
cette condition
ça c'est déjà un signe que les choix
diplomatiques et politiques de la france
au liban n'ont pas été concluante
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et donc il a fallu
passer à l'étape supérieure et 7,7 cette
position on a beaucoup attendu au liban
consignes on n'attend rien d'eux
directement de la france mais c'est un
signe que la stratégie française de
collaboration avec la classe politique
dominant depuis en trentaine d'années
hal est caduque
elle n'a pas réussi à n'a pas donné ses
fruits et justement à quel titre la
france sanctionne des responsables
politiques libanais en vertu de quoi
c'est à la france aujourd'hui de
sanctionner mais déjà la décision
française si c'est une décision pour
pouvoir faire secouer un peu
la stagnation et conduire à la formation
du gouvernement on a le droit ou bien il
faut annoncer c'est qui ces personnes là
il faut pas attendre une hausse qu'ils
prennent d'une visa de découvrir qu'ils
sont interdits de rentrer à nos
territoires français et d'autre part si
on a besoin d'un message politique face
à la corruption et à la halla halla on
va dire à tout à toutes les altitudes
mafieuse de la classe politique
libanaise
il faut les annoncer chose qui n'a pas
encore été faite alors que si on compare
avec les les américains c'est plus et
c'était plus clair et plus nettes
deuxième chose ce serait quoi la
position de la deûle à d autres pays
européens car pour parler très
clairement la fiq a cité deux de ces
types de sanctions est lié avec une
position européenne commune qui ne se
limite pas à la position nationale
française et sur ce point là c'est clair
que à travers des sources mais aussi on
l'a on a pu entendre directement les
esses plusieurs pays européens
critiquent la position française est
l'attitude française surtout après la
l'explosion de 4 août 2000 par et
notamment l'allemagne et l'allemagne a
donné plusieurs signes qu'elle n'est pas
tout à fait d'accord avec la stratégie
française qui se base sur une idée il
faut essayer de trouver une solution et
ne pas exercer beaucoup d'eux de
pression sur chris paul a notamment car
on peut pas trouver une solution sans la
caisse bonnart au liban et sur ce point
là je pense qu'il vient discorde entre
les américains et les français pendant
plusieurs mois alors qu'aujourd'hui je
pense que les français sont déjà arrivés
à un moment où ils savent très bien que
cette classe politique elle est
irresponsable
elle est incompétente et elle n'est pas
capable de faire aucun pas pour trouver
une solution durable ou bien le début un
début de sortie de la crise au libre oui
alors très rapidement on disait on ne
sait pas
de qui il s'agit en ces responsables
politiques et du banner sanctionné on ne
sait pas combien les sons et qui laisse
ont l'air de bien sûr bien sûr on a pas
on appelle avance le drian nous a
annoncé que la france a pris des
décisions contre qui on sait par le
nombre on sait pas de quel parti
politique à ce qu'ils sont de quel
niveau on parle de président de
ministres d'anciens ministres de hauts
fonctionnaires de députés on n'a pas de
solution
donc même les faits l'effet de choc qui
pouvait faire qui pourrait faire bouger
les choses on n'a pas entendu la chose
que je peux suivre les mentionner de
toute manière là bas si rapidement la
diplomatie française elle est toujours
prisonnier de la deûle à dudus de
silence total de l'administration
américain pour les américains il n'y a
pas de précipitation sur le site dans le
dossier inter libanais il y à d'autres
priorités et donc à mon avis personne ne
veut maintenant donner des compromis ou
bien donner des concessions alors que
les américains n'ont pas encore dit leur
dernier mot
ou plutôt leurs premiers mots sur la
situation s'est très rapidement un
monsieur mourad à quel point la
situation économique est catastrophique
au liban je vous donne est juste un
exemple personnellement en tant que
professeur de droit
mon salaire ils étaient autour de 4000 $
au tour 4000 euros là maintenant il est
au saut de 500 $ et large part loi une
autre classe moyens si on va le comparer
les comparer avec toute la situation de
la population libanaise
on est en train de vivre un écroulement
un effondrement total 1 les libanais
sont en train juste de tous les achats
tous les ménages audubon il juste pour
les pour les besoins mais juste les
besoins nécessaires fondamental pour le
pur ne survit au liban aujourd'hui on
vit pas on survit
monsieur mourad merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous depuis le liban
rappelle qu'il est professeur de droit
et activiste politique merci